There was very interesting breaking news
last night that the Senate majority leader,
Mitch McConnell, who of course is not just a
Republican but has been one of the most pernicious
Republicans to the causes of sanity and reason for
a long time and has been very effective at getting
endless numbers of right wing judges confirmed
successfully obstructed Barack Obama's Supreme
Court nomination of Merrick Garland back in
2016, that Mitch McConnell is reportedly pleased
about Donald Trump being impeached a second time.
Why? Because he believes it will make it easier
for the Republican Party to purge Donald
Trump to wash its hands of an association
with Donald Trump. Mitch McConnell has
told associates this has been reported by
The New York Times and confirmed by Fox News.
So take take your pick. At this point, Mitch
McConnell has told associates that he does believe
Donald Trump committed impeachable offenses
and that he is pleased that Democrats are
going forward with a second impeachment of
the president. He believes it will make it
easier to purge Trump from the party. And
at the same time, Representative Kevin
McCarthy of California, the minority
leader and a big supporter of Donald Trump,
has reportedly been asking other Republicans,
should I call on Donald Trump to resign? And
McCarthy has been personally against impeachment.
And he said he and other party leaders have
decided not to lobby Republicans to vote no. And
an aide to McCarthy said he's open to a measure
censuring Donald Trump in private. McCarthy
reached out to a leading House Democrat to see if
the chamber would be willing to look at a censure
vote instead of impeachment. Nancy Pelosi has
since ruled that out. So this is these truly
are unique times in American political history.
And when you take this together, McConnell is
pleased that impeachment is moving forward.
And McCarthy has been calling around saying,
what about censure? We're not going to lobby
for no votes on impeachment. What are we doing?
This reflects, depending on your perspective,
a come to Jesus moment for the Republican Party
or political posturing and opportunism.
Now, maybe you think I'm cynical,
but I think the answer is obvious. This
is political opportunism. And in fact,
I don't believe that McConnell is having a change
of heart on on Donald Trump. I believe McConnell
has had the same view on Trump all along. And
he said for as long as I can get judges through
and block things Democrats want to do will
sort of stand aside as Donald Trump does.
What he does here, by the way, is
the report I read to you is from
The New York Times, Laura Ingraham on Fox
News also saying they've confirmed McConnell
is not going to stand in the way of impeachment
and is, quote, done with Donald Trump or their
FOX News has confirmed that while he's not said
whether he supports conviction in the Senate,
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell is not
going to stand in the way of this impeachment
effort and is said to be done with Trump. Now,
given all that, and that ultimately is the key.
Does Mitch McConnell support conviction of Donald
Trump on impeachment? Will he vote to convict
when the Senate takes up this second impeachment
of Donald Trump with just minutes ago, as we've
been reporting here, was walked over by the House
impeachment managers to the United States Senate?
I don't know the answer to that. My instinct is
probably not. At the same time, Mitch McConnell's
wife, Elaine Chao, was one of the first to resign
in last week's run of resignations. She was Donald
Trump's transportation secretary. I believe
that this is nothing other than Mitch McConnell
doing what he likely planned to do for a long
time. Mitch McConnell has probably hated Trump
for a while. But like most Republicans, he was
either afraid of Trump's cult or calculating
that it didn't make sense to come out against
Trump to the extent that he could keep getting
judges confirmed and get tax reform done and on
and on and on. And so I don't think McConnell
deserves any any any praise for this.
What he wants is for Nancy Pelosi's name
and Democrats to be attached in public
to this impeachment. And he wants to hide
and figure out how he can use this to his
advantage to get this mess cleaned up,
the mess being the destruction that Donald Trump
has brought to the Republican Party. So there is
no praise here for Mitch McConnell. Complicity
due to being afraid is still complicity,
complicity or indifference due to political
opportunism or self aggrandizement or person. All
benefit, it's all just as bad Mitch McConnell got
his judges and now he wants to get rid of his old
baggage and it may work. Unfortunately, there is a
very short political memory in the United States.
We've already forgotten about things that happened
six months ago that appeared to be really big
deals at this point. And so the big narratives are
what matter. And the big narrative Mitch McConnell
wants is I didn't stand in the way of impeachment.
I used that second impeachment to try to wash our
hands of Trump. I got my judges done. We got our
Supreme Court justices and now let's get rid of
the baggage. None of them deserve to have their
reputations rehabilitated. I've said that a lot.
And that is all that this ultimately is. And
where I get to in the end is what I mentioned
before. Will Mitch McConnell vote to convict
in the impeachment trial of Donald Trump in the
Senate? I don't know the answer. Maybe tomorrow
I'll have some stronger feelings about it.